رغم قراري حل شرطه الاخلاق انتشرت في
ايران اليوم دعوات لبدء اضراب عام لمده
ثلاثه ايام اعتبارا من يوم الاثنين في
مسعى لمواصله الضغط
واسفلت دعوات مماثله للاضراب والتعبئه
الجماهيريه في الاسابيع الماضيه عن تصعيد
الاحتجاجات التي عمد البلاد الدعوات طالبت
بتنظيم احتجاجات اليوم الاربعاء المقبل
عندما يزور الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي جامعه
طهران ليلقي كلمه امام طلابها بمناسبه يوم
الطالب الايراني نبقى مع الرئيس الايراني
فبعد ما دعى في يوليو الماضي الى تعبئه
جميع مؤسسات الدوله لفرد قانون الحجاب عاد
على وقحه تواصل الاحتجاجات ليقول ان هناك
حلولا مرنه في دستور البلاد الذي صيغ عام
1979 يمكن تطبيقها لتغلب على اي مشكله
وفي خطاب له بمناسبه يوم الدستور الايراني
اضافر رئيسي ان دستور ايران ليس فيه اي
طريق مسدوده وان تنظيمه وصياغته يجب ان
تكون مرنه بما يضمن تنفيذ الدستوري واداره
شؤون البلاد
[موسيقى]
ثابته وغير قابله للتغيير جمهوريه النظام
واسلامته ومبدا الاستقلال والحريه والحقوق
والحريات التي يصرح بها الدستور اساليب
واليات لتطبيق القانون ولكن يمكن دراستها